the Arctic's 2080 and 20 atti are
finally out and we finally have a price
and performance of both of these cards
and unfortunately it is really quite
expensive but fortunately has never been
a better time to buy a 10 series GP
within right now welcome to Haris
hobbies so the 10 series across the
board has really great Pais right now
but NVIDIA has a lot of excess inventory
and they're trying to get rid of it as
soon as possible to do this they're
offering really great prices and we
should definitely take advantage of this
right now you can get a GPX 10 80 TI for
$600 on G takes ten seventy four three
hundred and fifty dollars a GTX 1060 for
$260 an RX 580 which pretty much has
identical performance to the GTX 1064
even less at $240 my personal favorite
the GTX 280 for four hundred and thirty
dollars currently now to put that in
perspective the original MSRP of the GT
X 1080 was $700 so right now it is
almost half that price pricing has been
really bad this year due to GPU mining
boom but finally all these cards are
under MSRP and these have the best price
that we have seen this entire year also
the r-tx 20 80 and 20 ATT are finally up
so we know the price and performance of
those cards as well it may be hard to
decide between the 20 series and
tempters before the 20 series launched
because you wouldn't know the price or
its performance but now that both series
are out is easy to decide between them
there are already hundreds of benchmarks
about the rkx 2088 28 ati and it is an
obvious choice for most people to go
with the 10 series due to the price and
performance AMD Navi does seem to be
coming out soon but honestly I can only
see up matching the performance of
Nvidia maybe for a potentially lower
price it will most likely not beat out
invidious performance and with the
tensor is being offered for such a great
value right now it probably won't beat
the value of the 10 series either and
if it does I really don't think I've has
worked at doing several more months just
to save a couple of dollars overall at
this point in time I think we have a
great view of all the options that we
have and so it really is a great time to
buy also the holiday season of 2018 is
just around the corner so you can wait
for Black Friday and other deals like
that like Cyber Monday and save even
more money than buying a ten series GPU
the Dead Sea is going to be discontinued
after the end of 2018 so the next two to
three months is in my opinion the best
time to buy a ten series GPU because
they will be offered for record low
prices you can get outstanding value out
of them for example you can probably
expect to get the GTX 1080 for less than
$400 which is absolutely insane
finally the 10th series offers great
performance which will last you a very
very long time
great racing is pretty much useless at
this point in time base even though our
TX 28 ET I can't really push a good
frame rate while ray-tracing so it
really just comes down to traditional
performance of the r-tx 2080 and 20 nati
versus the tensors and as far as that
goes
the archaic 2080 and 1080 ID are
separated by less than 1% difference in
terms of fps and in a lot of games at
1080p I actually performs better on top
of this the gtx 980ti it is over $200
cheaper than the RT x 2080 so you are
pretty much getting the same performance
for a much cheaper price like 75% of the
price overall my opinion is the best
time to buy a tensor GPU right now
because tensors pricing is so great and
it is honestly just going to get even
better also you have a clear view of all
of your options and what you have to pay
in the performance that you're going to
be getting out of them and the
performance difference between 10 series
and 20 series is not even that much in
the first place
so in my opinion if you're looking for a
GPU right now the best thing that you
can do is buy a 10 series GPU for a
really great price over the next one to
two months but that's just what I think
what do you guys think are you going to
be waiting for AMD navi or going
you have a tendency to GPU in the next
couple of weeks also what do you think
about aim DS 600 series do you actually
think that's going to come out soon make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like to do they make you drop a
like and consider subscribing if you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one but until then I'm Hardy I'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]